Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled
peppers hey guys I'm a Bri welcome to
Abby's kitchen as summer comes to a
close you're probably all heading to
that last barbecue wedding or carnival
all of which tend to be kind of like
super carb calorie fests I mean I had a
Willy Wonka themed wedding and a
champagne fueled honeymoon I definitely
overdid it on the sweet spot more than
one occasion this summer and let's be
honest a sugar fueled hangover never a
good time so a lot of people ask me what
actually happens when you overdo it on
speed so I thought I'd give a quick
little explanation so first of all we
get a surge of the feel-good hormone
dopamine which kind of tells us to go
and eat a lot more because it feels good
and then when sugar heats our
bloodstream insulin is released to take
those carbs to the muscles where they
can be used as energy the problem is
once our muscles have had enough they
get stored in our liver as glycogen and
once that's filled up they go to the old
fat cells really sucks we also tend to
get really hungry and shaky and cranky
because a lot of these refined carbs are
really fast digesting so just as soon as
they spike our blood sugar and our happy
happy hormones they crash it right back
down just as quick the good news is your
health is not a total bust after your
daily ice cream fixes summer okay so
there were a few days I ate ice cream
twice in a day that happened today
anyways I've got a great summer sugar
detox
that is totally a juice cleanse free tip
one don't diet the most important thing
to do after a sugar pinch or a summer
full of back-to-back vendors is to not
go into diet rival mode trust me the end
of summer sucks enough you don't want to
have to be going back to work on an all
celery diet I tried it
tip two don't weigh yourself you know I
hate this piece of crap honestly do not
let it suck you in if you do get on a
scale and you see a little bit of a bump
just keep in mind that a lot of sugar
can be accompanied by some water
attention and bloating so just pull your
Jets and burn this thing tip three eat
when you're hungry when you overdo it on
the refined sugar it's really important
to nourish your body to help you
restabilized your blood sugar and get
you back on track with your healthy
relationship with food so when you feel
hungry reach for a normal sized meal or
snack with foods that you actually enjoy
eating tip four reach for some protein
or fiber protein fiber are digested more
slowly than carbohydrates so they tend
to stabilize your blood sugar and keep
you satiated longer some of my favorites
are some really runny eggs with some
whole grain toast or some Greek yogurt
with an almond butter mix down tip 5 get
moving if you ate more pie than you're
happy to admit why don't use some of
that energy for a little light exercise
you don't to push yourself into
something strenuous when you maybe
you're feeling a little bit nauseous or
force yourself into filling you hate
because you're trying to undo the damage
but you think you're potentially done
just move your body in pleasurable
enjoyable ways like Zumba class guys get
your head out of the gutter
anyways exercise is a really great way
to help stabilize your blood sugar help
aid in digestion and to Goose confidence
tip 6 drink more water I know I'm not
the only one who checks out their pee in
the toilet and after overdoing on the
curve it's often like a very vibrant
yellow color that is my body telling me
that I need to up it on the h2o so focus
on flushing things out with some extra
fluids that will really help to speed
digestion reduce bloating and
the dreaded constipation tip 7 choose
probiotic rich boost Risa suggests that
a diet high in sugar can alter our
healthy gut bacteria so after awakening
from a carb coma I like to replenish
that gut bacteria with some probiotic
rich fermented foods like sauerkraut
kefir and yogurt see I told you that was
not so bad right I mean your body is one
smart cookie it does not need some $60
daily cleanse detox to get itself back
on track I would love to hear what some
of your sugar detox tricks are leave me
a comment below give me the thumbs up if
you're liking this video subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you next time
on hobbies kitchen